so yesterday I did a story about the
impending crisis that is Donald Trump's
internet censorship executive order
draft some of the details have leaked
and we are learning more and more about
the horrors of that executive order and
fortunately and I'm actually glad to see
this this story is getting more and more
attention a lot of people reacting to my
clip more than a hundred and ten
thousand views in the first twelve hours
I got dozens of emails more than two
thousand comments on that video and even
beyond that I am thrilled to see that
the story is getting pick up because
it's not like the sexiest most salacious
story it's not necessarily the story
that would get the most attention but it
is an authoritarian nightmare and people
are noticing and put simply this is how
the authoritarian start to use the law
to control speech and to enforce speech
and you might remember I was actually
thinking this morning as I was reading
about the reaction to this executive
order proposal Canadian Intellectual
Jordan Peterson rose to prominence for
what he claimed was his protest of
possible compelled speech by the
Canadian government he should be right
here protesting what Donald Trump is
doing because Donald Trump's drafted
executive order would compel social
media networks to have to allow speech
that the Trump administration determines
is so-called political speech and
specifically conservative political
speech to fight back against what they
claim is some kind of extreme liberal
bias in social networks and on platforms
Donald Trump believes that social media
platforms are in a biased way
suppressing and blocking conservative
speech the basis for this is a fantasy
but it doesn't change that this is
extremely dangerous it is overwhelmingly
authoritarian the White House shouldn't
have the power to select and choose what
content has to be allowed on social
media platforms it is stunning
that people like me social
left-libertarians
end up defending the rights of
corporations against the oppressive
authoritarian takeover of
speech that Donald Trump wants to do so
let me do my impression now of a
center-right libertarian social networks
are private companies they have to
follow non-discrimination law Twitter
can't say no White's allowed on our
platform YouTube can't say no Jews
allowed to upload videos or whatever
there is already established law that
prevents that Twitter can say we don't
allow the n-word we don't allow bullying
trans people by deliberately
misgendering them over and over and over
again or whatever this is all legal
content strictly speaking
which a private corporation can choose
to allow or not to allow based on their
business priorities their social
priorities or for whatever reason they
want as long as it does not violate
existing anti-discrimination laws this
doesn't mean I like it
this doesn't mean they always make the
decisions I would make this doesn't mean
that it couldn't conceivably cause me
problems the likes of which we've been
having on YouTube but we can't be
hypocrites what Trump wants to do is to
give the FTC the Federal Trade
Commission power to go after platforms
that the White House believes are
suppressing content on the basis of
political orientation on their platforms
and the scariest part is that it's
believed that there will be penalties
for this against the platforms what
those penalties will be we don't yet
know how far does this go do YouTube
channels with a million subscribers
become subject to similar restrictions
in a year when the david pakman show
YouTube channel hits a million
subscribers if things continue the way
they're going can the government save
this channel is suppressing certain
political opinions of the right can we
be fined can you suffer penalties and I
avoid slippery slope arguments in most
cases because they don't make sense this
is one of those cases where we really
need to think of the slippery slope who
counts as a possible regulate t of this
executive order when do we go from
regulating platforms to regulating
individual shows this is the biggest
attack on a free press
since sort of all the other attacks
we've seen under Donald Trump but this
is a really big one if you care about a
free press I don't care if your left or
right you must
poses this is the exact type of
heavy-handed media regulation that we
see under real bona fide authoritarians
in dictatorships in on a spectrum right
going from actual dictatorships to just
countries with leaders that are
authoritarian to the extreme China North
Korea Venezuela Russia whichever version
or flavor of authoritarianism you want
to pick out it's actually difficult to
put into words how dangerous this is if
this happens we become a country where
the government can do mass censorship on
the basis of political orientation or of
whatever it wants it lets the party in
power decide which speech is allowed on
the internet which speech must be
allowed on the Internet on specific
platforms and this is extraordinarily
dangerous now I'm going to keep talking
about this because it has to be stopped
and ultimately it may be a court that
decides whether the eventual version of
the executive order that is signed by
Trump is legal but that means that we
have to change who's choosing the judges
because it's Donald Trump right now
increasingly this is a justice system a
judiciary controlled by Donald Trump
more and more two Supreme Court justices
25% of appellate and Superior Court
judges this is not about whether you
like or dislike Trump we know how Trump
will use this but Trump will be gone in
two or six years do Republicans want a
future Democratic president telling the
FTC what speech is allowed on the
Internet
this is straight out of the
authoritarian dictators playbook it has
to be stopped I'm glad it's getting
attention and we're going to continue
talking about it